MALE SPEAKER: I
think it's running.
So welcome back to Devoxx.
We're here to talk about
more Android with Nicolas.
Welcome, Nicolas.
NICOLAS ROARD: Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER:
Nicolas, here you're
talking about effective image
manipulation on Android.
So obviously, Android is
a constrained environment,
because it's a
mobile environment.
What are the options
for developers
that they can use when
it comes to images?
NICOLAS ROARD: So there
are various options
that you can use
in your program.
The common ones are
probably OpenGL and native.
And those two actually
have a lot of issues
and a lot of constraints
that you have to deal with.
One of the recent
possibilities for Android
is Render Script, which is a
new framework, a new [INAUDIBLE]
for processing images that has
a lot of advantages compared
to those two other solutions.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so
we'll get to that,
and to your experience.
Anything against OpenGL
specifically, or native?
I mean, what are
the shortcomings
before we get to Render Script?
NICOLAS ROARD: No,
nothing particularly.
The only thing is
that I guess native--
by native, what I mean
is that you simply
pass a bitmap to the native it.
You process it.
It's pretty easy to process.
The problem is that if
you want to optimize,
you're going to have to
optimize for particular devices.
It's going to be difficult
to optimize for everything.
And compared to OpenGL,
it's a bit slower.
You also have to deal with
memory, et cetera, et cetera.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh,
back to native.
NICOLAS ROARD: All the
problems with native, right?
With some advantages,
some inconvenience.
OpenGL, the good thing is
that it should be fast.
The bad thing is well,
[INAUDIBLE] OpenGL
depends a lot on
drivers and some GPUs
appears better than others.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
NICOLAS ROARD:
And some GPUs have
constraints that
others do not have.
You have like a maximum size of
textures and stuff like that.
MALE SPEAKER: Right, OK.
So you're talking about this
because you have experience
with this, and you've
been building--
NICOLAS ROARD: I've been
working this past year basically
on the new photo
editing touring gallery.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
NICOLAS ROARD: Where
we actually started
the first version really is,
back last November, last year,
was mostly using
native processing.
We're just passing the bitmaps
through the native side,
doing something in
C, and that's it.
But since then, we moved a
lot more to [INAUDIBLE] Script
and for quite a few reasons.
The big difference
for us is that we
want the software to run on
as many devices as possible.
MALE SPEAKER: Of course, yeah.
NICOLAS ROARD: It
gets difficult if you
have to test and be 100%
sure that your code, OpenGL,
for instance, is going
to work everywhere.
So that's why we originally
went with native.
Even if it's not
as fast as OpenGL,
it's a more tractable
problem to be sure
that everything would work well.
But if we want to
make it faster to have
really good interactive
speed, then OpenGL
starts to look more appealing.
But then you end up
with all those issues
with compatibility,
and et cetera.
Render Script, on
the other hand,
has quite a few nice advantages.
One of the advantages is that
it's a specific language that
actually looks-- It's
basically C99 with vector
extensions, which
means that it's
both a good language for
image processing because
of those vector extensions.
So you can actually
write a version that
are cleaner and simpler
and make a lot more sense.
And at the same time,
it's not particularly
different than a [INAUDIBLE]
or that C. It's C99.
You basically use it as a VM
the compiler to generate that.
And then with the
detect the scripts
and execute it through VM,
do a bunch of optimization,
and more importantly, execute
all of that in parallel.
So in terms of
performances, what
you get is something that
is completely paralyzed,
that really takes
advantage of all the calls
on your device, which is
pretty important to us.
MALE SPEAKER: How about the GPU?
Can we use the GPU as well?
NICOLAS ROARD: And that's one
of the big thing this year,
is that we now support GPU
drivers for Render Script.
So on all the Nexus devices,
we do have GPU drivers.
MALE SPEAKER: But
what does it mean?
Do you get to choose as a
developer if it runs on one
of the other, what's
available, what's--
NICOLAS ROARD: So you can
either choose or not choose.
I mean, you have
the option, right?
So if you don't do
anything, Render Script
will just say I'm going to run
on the fastest possible thing.
You can also specify,
hey, I'm going
to run on the CPU,
which sometimes
is a really good thing to do
because the CPU is a lot more
predictable than the GPU.
So depending on what you
do, that might be better.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, interesting.
So just so people have an
idea of the work you've done,
this is the gallery, the
editor in the gallery.
There's a video online
available so people--
NICOLAS ROARD: Yes.
We posted it online and there's
some reviews this past week
about it.
So that's the [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: And you're doing
some pretty heavy lifting
with this.
It's not just adding
a simple filter
and being done with it, right?
NICOLAS ROARD: And I think
it's a good example of what
kind of script is there.
You can use it.
It works.
It's fast.
MALE SPEAKER: So give us
examples of, I don't know,
the type of transformation it's
doing, or work you're doing,
and the size of the image
maybe you're able to work with.
NICOLAS ROARD: Yeah.
So the way it actually works on
the arbitrary sizes of images.
MALE SPEAKER: And
it's non-disruptive.
NICOLAS ROARD: It's
non-disruptive.
We do a lot effects, not
just global effects, but also
local effects.
All the common ones, vignette,
contrast, saturation.
We do a bunch of interesting
things like that.
What I'm really happy with
is that it scales very well,
and it's non-disruptive, which
means that you can always
come back, reapply an
effect, change an effect,
and it's still going to
be at the same point.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
There's a pipeline
effect you apply,
and you can move back too.
And how about the previews?
Do you actually compute
those for the entire image,
or how do you make
that so snappy?
NICOLAS ROARD: In general,
the way you do it,
you can't actually run
everything on the full image
all the time because it's
going to be too slow.
So what you really care about is
to have something that is fast,
that is really
interactive for the user.
So you just shit.
What we do in the editor is
that we compute everything
on a very small preview image,
and because it's smaller,
we can run the stuff at
an interactive speed.
The UI elements themselves
are animated at 60fps,
so when you move something,
when you move a control,
it always follows
your actions, which
is really what's
the important point.
The preview itself is
very fast, and then
we have a progressive
preview, so as soon
as you start moving stuff, we
compute a higher resolution
image, and higher and higher,
until you get the final 1:1
image.
MALE SPEAKER: And you
have this nice way
of comparing before and after?
NICOLAS ROARD: Yeah,
there is some--
MALE SPEAKER: Some [INAUDIBLE].
Or the other way you apply.
I encourage people
to check it out
as end users, maybe
not as developers.
So great.
Where should people go to
learn more about Render Script?
NICOLAS ROARD: There
is some documentation.
Online.
MALE SPEAKER: Maybe--
NICOLAS ROARD: The documentation
that's there is sadly not as--
MALE SPEAKER: --comprehensive?
NICOLAS ROARD: --as I
would like it to be,
but the Render Script
team is working on that.
This past year,
the focus has been
more on getting out
compatibility library, which
means that-- and it's actually a
very important point-- it means
that you can write
from the script,
and you can run new applications
using [INAUDIBLE] scripts
on devices that go back to I
think Gingerbread [INAUDIBLE]
library.
But internally, we even
made it run on Froyo.
It's good.
That actually-- it's
very compatible.
It means I write
some code, and I
know it's going to
work everywhere.
MALE SPEAKER: That actually--
NICOLAS ROARD:
And yet it's going
to be fast and [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so the Android
website, there's documentation?
NICOLAS ROARD: Exactly.
On the website.
MALE SPEAKER: It's going
to get better over time.
But there's something
to start with.
Great, well Nicolas,
thanks for your time.
That's what I wanted to cover
here, and I'll see you soon.
NICOLAS ROARD: All right.
Thanks.